Lyle Matt congratulations you've made it
to the final round of this competition
when you showed up here you used our
Forge and our equipment to forge
bayonets
now we're sending you back to your home
forges to recreate an iconic blade from
history
the zuluiqua all right that's cool
the Zulu equal was introduced by the
famous Zulu King Shaka he reigned over
the Zulu Empire's expansion through
southern Africa from 1816 to 1828 a
celebrated warrior in his own right
Shaka developed a number of military
improvements for the Zulu including the
mandatory adoption of the aqua replacing
long light throwing Spears the equal was
shorter and featured a blade at least 10
inches long the spear wasn't thrown
rather it was thrust into the enemy and
would be carried along with a cowhide
Shield it was a fearsome weapon utilized
against British colonialists trying to
expand their African colonies the Zulu
equal was also wielded by Zulu warriors
in the classic film Zulu
it must be an effective fully functional
version of that iconic weapon
additionally it must have a double edged
Spearhead
I made Spears in the past I've
had people that wanted one to hunt with
I think I'll be able to do this very
successfully
you will have five days at your home
Forge to accomplish this task at the end
of those five days you will return and
present your weapons to our panel of
Judges we'll then subject them to a
series of dynamic tests only once those
tests are complete they declare one of
you the forged and fire champion who
also leaves with that check for 10 grand
good luck gentlemen we'll see you in
five days
you're lucky man all right man good luck
to you too
it's great to be back in my own shop
have all the best tools but I can
definitely get it done with everything I
have here uh Zulu ikawa that's something
I've never heard of I believe that's the
sound it makes when it goes in and pulls
out
my plan for the day is to get a point on
the piece of metal and then I'm gonna
have to figure out the Tang but I think
I'm gonna make a one-piece thing that'll
penetrate into the handle as well as
lock it down with some sinew
all right
today I'm gonna antique it a certain way
and then we'll get a handle attached I
like a lot of contrast so I got ferric
chloride over there that'll actually
turn this particular type of Steel black
and it's just going to fade into that
nice high polish it's just gonna look
really sharp
not bad not bad at all
time to start doing the handle
I'm having a leather wrap to this guy to
give a better grip I think it's going to
be nice to have something that pops a
little more than just a plain old handle
now if I wanted to start slicing some
stuff
wow
[Music]
I'm past all the forging I'm through
with the steel work now it's still in
the toughest part for me on the handle
I'm using zebra wood which comes from
central Africa that's going to make a
real nice look
to wrap the blade I'm using Pig
intestine and that's going to draw up
nicely and help hold it in tight It's
Tricky and it stinks
makes me hungry
[Music]
the only thing left to do is to test it
so I'm going to use the thickest part of
the blade
and see if it'll cut through in one full
swing
oh my goodness well let me try it one
more time
there you go
the equal with some African weapon used
by the Zulu warriors
though it's a short spear it also acted
like a sword because of its design to
see how sharp your blades are I will
take your weapon and try to cut through
the slab of meat while you're up first
you ready yes sir I'm ready
well Lyle your handle over here allows
me to grip and give it more weight at
the tip so when acting like a sword you
can really feel the power when you're
dropping down and as you can see it cut
cleanly through the meat overall sir
your weapon a little cut good job thank
you Matt you're up next you ready let's
do it seeing last blade cut like it did
I'm going ah crap I'm so nervous right
now
foreign
okay Matt a very light weapon like this
if held like a slashing sword could be
an issue when you have a rounded handle
makes it kind of hard to index but the
important thing is it will cut good job
thank you
this is a kill test the equa was so
deadly because up close you could use it
in different ways and maneuver the blade
to see how much lethal damage your
weapon can do I will deliver 4 killing
blows on this ballistic study while
you're up first you ready yes sir I'm
ready I've never tried to cut ballistic
dummies I'm anxious to see how it
performs
foreign
[Music]
your weapon here feels good in the hand
definitely it's easy to maneuver the
blade in different ways it's so sharp
that it lacerated and disemboweled the
gut right here it cuts through all the
way into the sternum right there
lacerating and then right into the heart
your weapon sir will kill thank you all
right Matt you're next you ready let's
do it
[Music]
well Matt you're leather wrapping on the
handle here made it very comfortable
your Edge over here is very sharp it
lacerated deep into the guts it went all
the way into the ribs the thrust deep
into the abdomen overall sir your weapon
will kill thank you all right next stop
is a strength test Dave so gentlemen
what we're going to do to test the
strength is we're going to tap the tip
of your blade into these blocks of wood
and then pry them to the side if your
blades are tempered properly it should
hold up beautifully and just pry a piece
of wood out if not
well we'll see so Matt you ready let's
do it
I can't believe he's actually gonna
drive it in like a nail and then torque
it back I'm just like freaking out I'm
like just don't break it's just don't
break on me
[Music]
that's not your blade it's okay okay
yes
we I did it
when I saw what I saw is I was prying
this out was that blade flexed quite a
bit at the tip and then that wood gave
way it's nice it's it's got just enough
movement that it didn't fracture the
neck's still true here hold on thank you
Lyle you're up next you ready yes sir
I'm ready
foreign
expecting the tip to break off my heart
just fell out of its place
and as I started to go to the side there
wasn't any Flex in that blade much at
all it just popped right off
everything's been fun but this looks dim
for me
the judges have made a final decision
the forged and fire Champion is
Matt congratulations congratulations
Matt thank you
while your blade did not make the cut
David will explain Lyle you brought us a
beautiful weapon felt great in the hand
it tested beautifully in two of our
tests but it came down to that strength
test that brittle tip snapping off
because of that we've got to let you go
okay
Lyle please surrender your weapon
thank you all for the opportunity it's
been a great experience once a tip broke
off I expected this I gave it my best
shot congratulations thank you I can go
home my head held high I enjoyed it I
made something I was proud of it was
just an oversight on my part
Matt congratulations you were the forest
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
that check for 10 grand good job thank
you
[Applause]
I hope you realize when I flexed that
blade to at least 45 degrees before it
popped that piece of wood out it scared
me when you did that and I thought you
scared me
this is amazing this is really cool I
can't believe I did it obviously what
you're going for but to have it happened
is
oh that's cool